.
>> Reporter: CIVILIAN AREAS.
>> Sean: SUCH STRENGTH AND
CLARITY END LIKE JOE'S AND
INSPIRING STATE OF THE UNION
SPEECH LAST NIGHT, INSTEAD OF
SHOWING REAL LEADERSHIP ON THE
WORLD STAGE, JOE BASICALLY RAN
OFF A WISH LIST OF REPACKAGED
BILL BACK BROKE PROPOSALS AND
OFFERED NO PLAN TO CURB
INFLATION.
NO PLAN TO DELIVER GAS PRICES,
NO PLANS TO SECURE THE BORDER.
NO PLAN TO REDUCE VIOLENT CRIME.
NO TO COUNTERS CHINA AND BY THE
WAY, TAIWAN, I WOULD ARGUE, KEEP
A CLOSE EYE ON IT.
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE THAT
LONG.
HE DID NOT EVEN BOTHER TO
MENTION THE 13th U.S. SOLDIERS
WHO DIED AS A RESULT OF HIS
DISASTROUS WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN THE AMERICANS WHO
HAVE BEEN TRAPPED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
TO DATE, BY THE WAY, IS DAY 200
JOB ABANDONED THEM.
JOE AND THE MEDIA NOT ONLY
ABANDON THEM.
THEY TURNED THE PAGE.
THEY MOVED ON.
PRETTY UNFORGIVABLE.
JOE ALSO DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE
MUCH OF A PLAN TO ASSIST THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE, BUT HE DID
MANAGE TO CALL THEM IRANIANS,
LEAVING THE VICE PRESIDENT-ELECT
EMBARRASSED.
TO MAKE THEY WILL NEVER GAIN THE
HEARTS AND SOULS OF THE IRANIAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: UKRAINIANS, NOT
IRANIANS.
ONE OF MANY AWKWARD MOMENTS FROM
A VERY SIMPLE SPEECH, ONE THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN WRITTEN BY A
FIFTH GRADER THAT STILL PROVED
TOO DIFFICULT FOR OUR STRUGGLING
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF IF YOU
DECIDE.
>> President Biden: WE SPENT
MUCH BUILDING COALITIONS IN
EUROPE.
WE ARE CUTTING OFF THE LARGEST
BANKS, PREVENTING RUSSIA'S
CENTRAL BANKS FROM DEFENDING THE
RUSSIAN RUBLE.
AND A POUND OF UKRAINIAN PEOPLE,
PROUD, PROUD PEOPLE, POUND FOR
POUND, READY TO FIGHT WITH EVERY
INCH OF ENERGY THEY HAVE.
YOU CAN'T BUILD A WALL HIGH
ENOUGH TO KEEP OUT A VACCINE.
THE VACCINE CAN STOP THE SPREAD
OF THESE DISEASES.
BAN ASSAULT WEAPONS AND
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
OVER 100 THANKS.
DO YOU THINK THE DEER ARE
WEARING KEVLAR VESTS?
AND MAY GOD PROTECT OUR TROOPS.
THANK YOU.
GO GET HIM.
>> Sean: GOAT TO GET?
TRYING TO EMULATE LARRY THE
CABLE GUY, TRYING TO GET 'ER
DONE?
OVER 81-YEAR-OLD SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE NANCY PELOSI, IT WAS
HAVING HER OWN MALFUNCTION IN A
VERY LOOK AT HER JOYOUS REACTION
TO BIDEN'S COMMENTS ABOUT BURN
KIDS IN THE IRAQI WAR.
YOU CAN EXPLAIN THIS TO BE
BECAUSE I CAN'T.
>> President Biden: FACING
MANY DANGERS.
ONE BEING STATIONED THAT
BREATHING IN TOXIC SMOKE FROM
BURN PITS.
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN THERE.
I HAVE BEEN IN AND OUT OF IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN OVER 40 TIMES.
THESE BURN PITS INCINERATE
WASTE.
>> Sean: CAN SOMEONE EXPLAIN
THAT TO ME?
I DIGRESS TAKE THE SCOPE VICE
PRESIDENT, MATT HARRIS AND
KAMALA HARRIS BRILLIANTLY
DESCRIBED THE CONFLICT IN YOUR E
THIS.
UKRAINE IS THE COUNTRY IN
EUROPE.
IT EXISTS NEXT TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY CALLED RUSSIA.
RUSSIA IS A BIGGER COUNTRY.
RUSSIA DECIDED TO INVADE A
SMALLER COUNTRY CALLED UKRAINE.
SO BASICALLY, THAT IS WRONG.
OKAY.
WHEN YOU ADD THESE THREE